[Music]
with millions of people working from
home during the pandemic many of us have
had the free time to
look up at the night sky one resource
that is rapidly disappearing though is
darkness
our country is bathed in artificial
light which means dark skies are
disappearing mystery wire's george knapp
has our story
one of the brightest spots on the planet
the las vegas strip is a tourism and
economic beacon even during the pandemic
but all of this light comes at a cost
it spills out into the night sky
blotting out the stars
and our connection to the cosmos the
number of places that are truly dark
at night is shrinking fast light
pollution is not only an
environmental issue but a health concern
we
humans evolved like all life on earth
and bright days and dark nights and we
need both
for optimal health and so our bodies
have never had a chance to
evolve to adjust to all this bright
light at night
a growing body of scientific evidence
documents the physical
and emotional consequences of light
pollution but it's hard to quantify what
it means to lose sight of the milky way
can dark skies be protected the story on
mysterywire.com
george knapp reporting